I'm not expecting violins here but I am
a human being as well as a politician
there is a much greater intensity did I
see it brutality to Life as a politician
than in Years Gone by
her departure a bombshell which exposed
the smp's lack of a succession plan
before a divisive contest to replace her
got underway
and you can sit here and feel free to
attack the snp's record in the
Queensbury Crossing I don't think it's
going to do I'm not attacking the Earth
your suggestion I suggested that it
wasn't as successful no I did not say
that don't put words in my mouth and why
do you think I'm more trusted to tackle
the cost of living crazy
and now a fresh controversy a row over
transparency as full sturgeon's husband
to quit as the smp's chief executive
[Music]
the question many people are asking
though is why did Nicholas sturgeon quit
in the first place and why now was it
the failure to secure Scottish
independence lingering questions over
party donations or could recent setbacks
be to blame like the UK government
blocking a controversial Scottish bill
on gender recognition earlier I sought
some answers first Minister thank you
for joining us today and I want to talk
to you about your decision to stand down
your Reflections on your time as fast
Minister but before I do I want to ask
you about the events of the weekend your
husband Peter Morrow resigned this
weekend as SNP Chief exec the director
of comms also resigned after it emerged
departured live to the Press about
membership numbers to quote the interim
Chief exec Michael Russell the party's
in a tremendous mess
I don't think the party's in a
tremendous mess and I don't actually
think that's what Mike meant uh some of
the issues around the leadership
election have you know created this
impression of it being messier than we
would like it to be but the process is
fundamentally sound the party is
undefeated electorally I'm struck by the
fact most parties who go through a
process like this do it after an
election defeat that's not the position
the SMP is in we're going through what I
would describe as necessary Growing
Pains it is difficult but I think we'll
come out of it stronger and perhaps the
tricky thing given we are undefeated
electorally still by some distance
Scotland's biggest political party it's
to get the balance right between the
renewal change refresh that is necessary
I wouldn't be standing down if I didn't
think that was necessary after 16 years
in government but also protecting the
ingredients of our phenomenal electoral
success not throwing the baby out with
the bath water so difficult process yes
but the city one for the party and I'll
I'll come on to why you decided now not
after an election which should be a more
typical moment to stand down but the
fall in memberships really quite
disastrous isn't it no it's not
disastrous and I think context and
perspective is important of course no
party wants its membership to be going
down rather than up but immediately
after the independence referendum we had
an explosion in membership to a very
very high point that was probably not
sustainable forever that has settled now
around the the place that's been
published over the weekend there'll be a
variety of reasons in that some
political you know some people forget to
sign up the cost of living crisis will
be a factor as well but the perspective
that is really important for my party to
hold on to here is that we Remain the
only Mass membership party in Scotland
and we don't we can't see this with
certainty because the other parties
don't publish their membership figures
but based on the assessments of that we
will have more members in the SNP e then
all of the opposition parties I don't
want to dwell it but it is 30 000
members lost over a year it's it it is a
lot and and you're going through a bumpy
time the party not looking that
attractive at the moment but I I
actually actually so I'm not I'm not
suggesting that this is not a difficult
process and at times it has been a less
than edifying process and what I'd say
to all of those standing to succeed me
as leader I'm not picking a favorite
there that's for the party to decide is
remember that I am standing down from a
party that hasn't lost an election in
Scotland since 2010 we've won eight
elections in my years as leader we
remain significantly ahead of all the
other parties in the opinion polls even
opinion polls in in recent days we've
built a coalition of support and an
election winning campaign machine so yes
the fact I'm standing down is Testament
to the fact that I think after so long
in government this is a moment for
refresh renewal change but let's not
throw the baby out with the bath water
we have the trust of the people of
Scotland and we've got to make sure we
retain that trust Nicholas Stone it
sounds a bit like you're making a
warning to them about trash no I'm not
warning anybody I'm uh I'm really
careful because I I've said I'm not
going to give unsolicited advice to
those who come after me and and I mean
that but what I'm saying is most
political parties go through this after
the elected it have kicked them out
that's not the smp's position we are the
most successful party in Scotland the
most trusted party the biggest party
even in this difficult phase by far so
we've obviously been doing lots of
things right yes we need to any party
that doesn't change after you know
getting close to two decades in power is
is Daft in my view
but make sure we get the balance right
between change and protecting what has
made us so successful and just before I
move on there's also an ongoing police
investigation to use of funds we
wouldn't expect you to comment on that
but there's a suggestion you and your
husband will be interviewed have you
heard anything on that no but I am not
going to comment on I wouldn't comment
on any ongoing police investigation and
I'm not going to comment on this one so
you haven't heard but
it must have been put pressure on you
and your husband hand on heart did this
play any part in your departure and your
decision no
um well look let's move on to your
resignation you're standing down after
nearly a decade as fast Minister this is
the first time I've I've seen you do an
interview since your shot resignation
and I have to say I watched that
resignation press conference somewhat
aghast you'd said you'd fight the next
general election you said it would be a
de facto Independence referendum and
then out of the blue you quit
not directed to you but
Scottish journalists now described my
announcement as a shock and out of the
blue many of them have spent the last
couple of years speculating that I was
about to do exactly that so you know
perhaps not quite as as out the blue as
as many thought every time I've said
that I'm going to fight the next
election and carry on I've meant it
um but I became
I suppose ever more conscious of the
fact that every time I said it I was
having to work harder Within Myself to
convince myself of that I mean to give
some context I've I've been first
Minister for more than eight years I've
been in government for 16 years but I've
been in politics for 30 years I've done
this for my entire adult life being
first minister
like being leader in any country is 24
7. you're never off duty there have been
some really difficult periods over the
last eight years the covet experience
was the most mentally and physically
challenging I've ever gone through so
taking all of that I just got to the
point where I thought could I Soldier on
for longer undoubtedly could I leave my
party to more electoral success I
absolutely believe that but could I for
much longer give the job what it
deserves and the only way I could do it
is 100 of myself and the answer to that
was no I mean actually Jacinda her and
who you have been compared to the the
former prime minister of New Zealand
said she didn't have enough in the tank
you said you didn't have the stamina is
that is that how you felt you just
didn't have enough in you anymore I can
only do this job and I think
anybody should only ever do a job like
this if you can give it everything and
that's not just a hundred percent of
your work a job like this you give
everything of yourself you're never off
duty I can't I'm not complaining about
this it's part of parcel of what the job
is about I can't just open my door and
go for a walk with a friend of a
Saturday morning I can't go for a cough
all the things people take for granted
are not there for you and I think there
is only so long anybody
can and should do that so that's the
personal reason and traditionally in
politics maybe because it's tended to be
more men than women doing it there has
been a tendency to cling on beyond the
point you should step back I prefer
doing it this way to step back maybe a
bit before it was absolutely the point
where everybody thought I should but
arguably Nicole sturgeon you stepping
back now is leaving the party in a
whilst position than it would be for all
of the difficulties you've had over them
not political months the party is going
to be in a worse position
back I don't think that's it looks like
a mess at the moment we're going through
a difficult period just now but I
believe we'll emerge stronger from that
for any political party any organization
you cannot be forever
overly dependent on one individual that
and that's part of the re we need to
be able to move on there is a wealth of
talent in the SNP we need to allow that
to come forward part of the reason going
beyond my personal and if I can't give
it 100 personally I'm not doing my party
any favors by staying on longer but one
of the reasons beyond that for me
stepping down is that because I've been
around for so long you become so
dominant in the political discourse that
you actually start to Eclipse other
people and the talent that is there so
is this difficult and yes will we come
through it yes and in terms of where I
leave my party
I am bequeathing to my successor a party
that is undefeated electorally in my
entire leadership a party that remains
the biggest in Scotland that's a
brilliant foundation for anybody in
which to build and I listen carefully to
what you said about how maybe male
politicians in power Klingon until they
get shoved out whereas you're leaving on
your own terms when you have decided but
I'm curious still was there a change in
your personal life was there something
that tips you over the edge or you just
felt fatigued I made on the day I I made
the announcement I think I spoke in
Butte house for about 20 minutes and in
that speech are the reasons for the
decision and I know you know there's
always a temptation to look behind that
and say there must be some hidden reason
there's not I kind of poured my soul out
of that day partly it's personal I have
you know I entered I joined the s p at
16. I entered Parliament at 29 I became
Deputy first minister 37
are about to be 53. I've been Nicholas
dodging the politician for all of my
life I want to in the next phase of my
life spend a bit more time on Nicholas
dodging the person and contribute to the
causes I care about in a different way
but for my party in the country I also
think after a certain period of time
change is healthy for any democracy I
you know it sounds as if I'm bigging
myself up here I'm not meaning to I
can't dominate Scottish politics which
is not always healthy it obscures and
distorts debate on other issues so this
is the right time to go can I can I put
it another way if we go back to a hand
because there are lots of parallels like
you her you're a credible Communicator a
formidable politician and like her
you've left your party potentially in a
worse shape going into an external
election than under your leadership your
decision has genuinely surprised the
party succession planning doesn't seem
to be thought through its could you
aren't you irresponsible you you because
they're not ready to succeed you you
there was a succession plan when you
became first there was an association
plan that was me and you know you are
the succession plan but there is only so
much I've put people into my cabinets
into my government I've allowed people
to you know get the ministerial
experience and the political experience
that comes with that but ultimately it
comes down to people stepping up and
we've got three people who have stepped
up in the party will choose if you go
back you know to you know 10 years or so
ago people would have looked at me and
thought was she really capable you know
she'd never be Alex almond she would
never be able to sometimes you have to
allow people to get into the position in
order to prove themselves and you become
and I felt I was becoming not because I
didn't want to do and didn't try to do
it I was becoming the barrier to
succession because I was eclipsing at
those that would come after me wouldn't
you have stayed until the next general
election I could have done but I at what
cost to myself at what lost ultimately
because if it is and I don't believe
it's the case I think my Party
fundamentally is in a very strong
position but if your argument is correct
and I would just have been staying on
because I was effectively papering over
cracks or keeping a lid on a pressure
cooker or whatever is that in the
long-term interest of my party my party
is going through up process of change
right now that is difficult change is
always difficult but it's essential if
it is to come out of that process
stronger and ready not just to fight the
next general election but to fight the
contest and when the case for
Independence that comes after is that
any part of you while you watch what's
going on now and the suddenly you know
Kate Forbes had to come back from
maternity leave and there was a big
scramble around and they didn't really
have their campaigns ready is there any
part of you that thinks
oh maybe I mishandled this no no because
nothing at all I'm My Own biggest critic
okay even sitting in front of people
like you so I'm the kind of person that
will always agonize over could have done
that better could have done this better
but
just let's play this thought experiment
for 20 seconds here see I decided to
stay on for another six months a year to
the general election whenever that was
going to be
couldn't have said six months in advance
by the way I'm about to stand down
because you can't govern like that so
whenever I had chosen to stand down now
six months a year 18 months from now
there would still have been a sense that
it had come out of the blue because the
nature of it is that you know until you
decide to step down you are the person
in the hot seat and you have to have all
of the authority that goes with that so
what I'm saying in it you know maybe
I'm not trying to to Simply justify my
own decision I don't need to justify my
own decision but there's an
inevitability after you know the SMP has
only three people lead it in 30 years
it hasn't had to go through this for a
while but frankly every year now that
this process was delayed would arguably
have made the process harder than it is
we will emerge from that doesn't feel
like it just now readily can see going
into a general election we will come out
of this to lose your most successful
leader at The Ballot Box is there's a
downside risk put it that way you must
see that of course but there would be an
outside risk of me staying on beyond the
point at which I thought I was the right
person okay personally and politically
yeah I spoke in my resignation speech
about the fact that lots of people
because there are very there's nobody in
Scotland very few people in Scotland
with an opinion of me good bad or
somewhere in between and that starts to
color people's opinions of other issues
as well
in democracy change is essential in a
healthy democracy it is inevitable and
inescapable it's never easy particularly
when you've gone a long period without
it but I actually think in standing down
now rather than six months or a year
from now I'm giving my party the ability
to go through this process come out of
it stronger and be fighting fit for the
general election when it comes if your
party lose loads of seats and the
general election will you look back on
that and remember well I don't believe
my party will lose loads seats in the
general election then I will play my
partner as leader but in you know
different capacities at making sure my
party fights the general election and
fights it to win just a few more things
now you're leaving the political fight I
do want to ask you I'm not leaving
politics I'm leaving no the leadership
fight then I wanted to answer that piece
of legislation that caused you some
difficulty which was the gender
recognition bill you stuck to your guns
but it was a relatively marginal issue
in you know in relation things like the
NHS or educational drugs in Scotland and
you burnt through a huge amount of your
own political capital
and you were out of step with the
Scottish public do you look back on that
and think you got it wrong
um
firstly I I think I could sit here and
argue that I wasn't outside with the
Scottish public but I don't know that
there's much point in having a backwards
and forwards about opinion polls okay
secondly the other thing I would take on
is in in leadership you never do one
issue at the expense of others you deal
with a multitude of issues so this idea
that because I I pursued gender
recognition legislation we didn't focus
on other issues the other contextual
point I would make is and this this
actually illustrates the point I was
making earlier on this legislation is
described in Scotland as my legislation
this piece of legislation was passed by
a two-thirds majority in the Scottish
parliament msps of every party voted for
it wasn't my legislation it was
legislation but democratically by the
Scottish Parliament if I have a regret
about it it's not pursuing an issue but
I don't think equality basic human
rights and human dignity is ever a
marginal issue I've had I've sat in
rooms with young trans kids talking to
me about one kill themselves because of
the stigma and the discrimination and
the inability to be recognized for who
they are I don't think that's a marginal
issue I'm a feminist always have been
always will be the threat to women are
abusive and predatory men not trans
people so I don't regret taking on that
issue remember Scotland was far from the
first country to do this many other
countries have similar legislation
already in place my regret is that I
wasn't able to take the debate in the
discourse around it into a more rational
place not to get everybody to agree with
me that was never going to happen but to
help ensure that we could debate it
reasonably civilly and rationally and
maybe that's part of what I've been
seeing here maybe I've been in politics
for too long now to be able to do that
as effectively as I need is it not your
confidence that you can win the argument
no I didn't no I didn't know my
confidence but it
it wasn't I said when I made my
resignation statement there was no one
issue
people said at the time well this has
been a tough time for the Scottish
government show me a time that's not
been tough if this was just about the
confidence the resilience to deal with
individual ups and downs of politics I
wouldn't be standing down
but it's about
That central point I made when you've
been in politics in as dominant a
position as I have for as long as I have
then
your ability to change people's minds
about you and about issues that you're
arguing diminishes you and that's the
reality and first Minister you also got
into a model over Isla Bryce and a
convicted rape is sent to a all-woman
prison uh you've got into a model about
whether they were a man or a woman first
you said shouldn't have enough
information then you describe Bryson as
her do you regret all of that as well I
don't
the Scottish prison service has been
dealing with trans prisoners for years
and it's been dealing with trans
prisoners safely and effectively and so
do I I don't regret if I fail in any
respect on any issue to communicate
things as clearly and as properly as I
can then I always you know regret the
fact that I've done that but
you know these are tough issues but
their issues fundamentally about basic
human rights and my point on either it
seems right I've campaigned for women's
rights I've fought for women's rights
all my life and always will do my point
and that it goes exactly to my point
there is no other group in society
where we take the behavior of a tiny
minority and use it to deny rights to
the whole of that group the vast
majority of trans women
the vast overwhelming majority of trans
women never commit any crime against
women or any other crime absolutely a
minority in every group will be bad
faith actors that do terrible things we
deal with them that and that's the point
I made about Isla Bryson what gender
that person said they were was less
important than the fact they were a
rapist a convicted rapist and that's how
they're dealt with in the prison service
but the fact that they were a convicted
rapist should not have been used by
anybody as a pretext for denying rights
to the broader trans Community you
female leader feminist Nick JK Rowling
wore a tease saying Nicholas sturgeon
destroyer of women's rights in 2022 did
that hurt no because it's not true and
when things are you angry I wasn't angry
I look things don't hurt you if they're
fundamentally not true I'm not going to
JK
um was you know a huge Harry Potter fans
though love Harry Potter I'm not going
to get into sparkly JK railing I've got
no one she's entitled to her views but I
know where I stand on women's rights I
know what I've fought forward and
campaigned for all my life on women's
rights one thing I would see one other
thing I would say here and please before
I see it it's not a comment directed at
JK Rowling absolutely no it's a general
comment
but
you know one of the other things that
you know I've spoken about lots of
people speak about these days is is the
abuse that women in public life get that
is much more intense than any time in my
political career and I had any of the
whole trans debate is and I accept you
know the scrutiny robust scrutiny that
comes with the job that I do
private more toxic abuse on this issue
much of it
from women claiming to care about
women's rights and women's safety then I
have them probably any other issue and I
think all of us need to take a step back
and reflect on that we can disagree and
obviously do disagree on this issue
but whether it's on this issue or other
issues we need to learn relearn how to
disagree in a way that is civilized and
respectful and brings a bit of good
faith back into some of these yeah
partly though because women feel that
they are their rights are being ignored
that why women are feeling angry about
it well some women are feeling angry
about it many many women are not I am a
woman women's rights matter to me more
than almost any other issue I've grown
up like most women have experience and
at different parts at different times in
my life the
the fear of being attacked by by men it
is predatory men and the I are abusive
towards women that's what we need to
focus on we also need to in my view as a
feminist we need to focus much more on
the real threats there are to women's
rights around the world right now
Reproductive Rights are under more
attack than they have been in my life
probably
in many parts of the world women still
don't have basic human rights and
dignity many girls still can't go to
school
misogyny sexism all again sealed largely
by social media on the rise there are
plenty real threats to women's rights
and women's safety right now and I think
we should focus more on them rather than
on things that perhaps are not
the key so when Kate Forbes says that
she would like protection zones around
abortion clinics with balance and we
don't know what that means does that
worry you I'm not going to make a
comment on Kate Hamza Ash anything
that's in the leadership election
because it's from my party to decide on
these issues I'll speak for myself
um we're seeing in Scotland's not unique
here protests outside abortion clinics
now that I think are wrong it's not the
protest that there's wrong people in a
democracy have a right to protest but
come and protest outside of parliament
where laws are made not where women are
accessing basic health care which is
what abortion services are and I am a
big supporter of effective buffer zones
legislations recently been passed in
England for for buffer zones Northern
Ireland have it I want to see Scotland
do the same and I'll be an advocate for
that from the back benches I've got two
more questions we'll toast you out of
time
um this week you've got your final first
ministers questions your final tablet
you're doing a big spit you're doing a
yay there I was going to ask you
um number one it must feel weird yeah
yeah
it's been
since I made the announcement I've been
a mix of emotions I I don't mind
seeing that
um and I'll be a mix of emotions this
week as I go through these final acts
cabinet first ministers questions
this is the biggest life change I've
probably ever gone through it's it's
going to be a big transition and I'm
going to have to adapt and it will take
time but in all of that mix of emotions
in the last few weeks I've never doubted
that I'm doing the right thing and and
that's in my my core I feel that in my
my gut would you ever come back or is
this it you would you are you ruling out
a Nicholas Sergeant combat that is not
going to be a nickel Sergeant comeback
there's nothing I just want to ask you
about your final act one of your
finances first Minister because it was
to announce the launch of a memorial
book for those who have experienced
pregnancy or baby loss it's an
experience that you went through in 2001
servants adopted too fast and it's
particularly poignant today because it
was Mother's day yesterday and you know
you would have had a child that was you
know in double digits now it's something
we don't talk about enough
is that why you wanted to do that that
you wanted that to be part of your
legacy to try and allow women the space
to talk about this publicly if they want
to it's it's not just because I had that
experience me having that experience has
given me an understanding of why that's
so important to women who go through
early baby loss and and miscarriage so
yes I I think it's important I look back
on my experience and if
if there had been the ability to have
the
you know the child that you hoped that
pregnancy would become recognized
recorded in some way I think that would
have brought some comfort and I do think
it's important that we talk more openly
about these experiences miscarriage
menopause at another stage of life that
women go through but have been for so
long
cloudy and shouted and in stigma and a
bit of embarrassment and I think we need
to open all of that up to much greater
discussion and and embrace it okay well
Nicholas stage and I don't know what
you're going to do next me neither but
we will all be watching uh to see and
thank you for joining us today really
appreciate it thank you thank you
Nicholas sturgeon there with a poignant
message and what's likely to be one of
her final interviews as first Minister
and I wonder what she'll do next well I
hope you enjoyed this week's
conversation if you scan this QR code on
screen now you can watch all of our
interviews online and all of the
previous episodes of the show
and if you scan the QR code on screen
right now you can also listen to the
Beth Rigby interviews podcast each week
I take a look at the highlights of my
interviews and there are some extra bits
and pieces in there too that'll be on
the Sky News app or wherever you get
your podcast later this week
well that's all for today's show thank
you to my special guest Nicholas
sturgeon and thank you for watching
thank you
[Music]